i'm not smarter than anybody else but i
can outwork you
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself it's never work
when you're pursuing your ambition it's
just it's just who you are
it's your soul it's your being wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
rich people habits
that you need to try enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one out work
yourself with michael bloomberg the one
thing
i i'm not smarter than anybody else but
i can outwork you
and uh my key to success for
you or for anybody else is make sure
you're the first one in there every day
and the last one to leave
don't ever take a lunch break or go to
the bathroom you
keep working you never know when that
opportunity is going to come along and
at solomon brothers
uh the managing partner of the company
bill solomon was the
second person in i was the only other
one in the big trading room
so if he had needed to borrow a match in
those days people smoked cigars
and if he wanted to ask something about
a newspaper or a stock
he came over and so we became buddies i
would never have
gotten to talk to the managing partner
of a big company
on a first name basis if it wasn't for
the fact that the two of us are there
billy i'm getting coffee would you like
some uh and i can bring you
that and at the end of the day the
number two guy john good friend he was
the last one to leave
except for me and we'd share a cab going
uptown or take the subway train going
uptown together
and you know every opportunity ever had
it was
i think a lot a lot of them was because
i was there at the time
and that's the one thing you can control
you can you can't control your luck but
the harder you work the luckier you get
you can't control that you're the
smartest guy they'll always be somebody
smarter
but if you're there then you absorb
things
you put things together in a ways that
if you didn't have all that experience
it's like skiing i've said reading a
book on skiing
doesn't teach you how to ski you got to
go and you got to
ski and get lots of miles under your
skis
and incidentally if you don't fall
you're not skiing hard enough and you're
not learning anything
so if your career has ups and downs i
got fired didn't turn out so bad
but you know you can start a little
business and maybe it doesn't work and
after a while you got to say be smart to
say hey i tried it
don't let your ego get in the way i
can't keep doing this i've got to earn a
living
but you know a year from now i'm going
to come up with a better idea and then
i'll go back and do it again
and have that drive to look at the
bright side and i've with the exception
of
um i've always i've never it's never
been a day that i haven't looked forward
to going into work even the days i knew
i was going to get beaten up
even the day i knew i was going to get
fired i'd never been fired before i
wonder what it's like
okay let's go find out yeah and i've
never
looked back i i i find it fascinating
people spend and we're doing this in
this country
we're spending all our time trying to
blame people and figure out why we got
to where we are now
rather than focusing on how you get out
of where we are now and make it better
and successful people look to the future
and unsuccessful people look to the back
look behind them
habit number two invest in yourself with
warren buffett
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself i mean that
for example communication skills i tell
the students that come that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas all that
if they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and
in person they increase their value at
least fifty percent no
i mean uh if you can't communicate
somebody says
you know it's like winking at a girl in
the dark nothing happens you know
basically and and
you have to be able to get get both your
ideas
and uh and that's that's relatively easy
i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course some
people wish i'd taken a shorter course
now
in terms of my talking later on but it
it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself
nobody can take it away from you habit
number three just
say yes with eric schmidt what i say to
everybody
that i meet who ask me sort of how to
how to organize themselves what i do is
i tell them to say
yes say yes to things
just say yes just say yes figure out a
way to do it
find a way to say yes to things say yes
to invitations to a new country say yes
to meet new friends say yes to learn
something new
yes is how you get your first job your
next job your spouse even your kids
even if it's a bit edgy a bit out of
your comfort zone saying yes means that
you'll do something new meet someone new
and make a difference
yes lets you stand out on a crowd be the
optimist
see the glass full be the one that
everyone comes to
yes is what keeps us all young habit
number four
build ambition with kevin o'leary
ambition
the desire to go somewhere the myopic
focus that there's something you're here
for a reason and you want to get that
done
whatever that is for you it's never work
when you're pursuing your ambition it's
just it's just who you are
it's your soul it's your being and i
think that's what makes great
entrepreneurs are great leaders they
they want to get up in the morning they
want to do what they
you know what their ambition is telling
they have to do ambition is a drive it's
a vision it's a drive
let's talk about writing books because
i'm working on my fourth now
i'm hating every minute of it but i
think it's going to be my best but
i always say that about every book how
do you do yours
this book came when i was on tour last
year and
i was hitting the city every four days
and doing a speech in front of a group
and
the questions that people asked me i
just kept
kept like a note of what people kept
asking me over and over again and then
it turned it into
and then you you got thematically you
would get some very
questions over and over again that
people had right you'd say that is a
kernel that's an important question
because they keep getting it all the
time is that the idea
yeah i was on tour and people kept
asking me how do i find my purpose how
do i find my purpose how do i find my
prayers like
the number one question in every city
across america
i said well that's pretty easy you don't
have to
sit on top of a mountain for 10 years or
hire 20 000
business coach you know there's a
three-step process to find your purpose
and i just guided them through it and
then everyone say pick me pick me do it
with me it's like okay well
i'll turn it into a book and that became
built to serve sounds good
i gotta read that book man that sounds
pretty good i gotta find my purpose
i've really enjoyed our time today it's
great you're a good guy
i'm going to endorse you
that's fantastic habit number five take
that risk with jeff bezos
life is full of different risks and i
think that the when you think about the
things that you will regret when you're
80.
they are almost always the things that
you did not do
they are acts of omission they're not
you're not very rarely are you going to
regret something that you did and it
failed and didn't work or whatever
but the acts of omission the thing you
know it's not and again i'm not just
talking about business things it's like
you know uh i loved that person and i
never
told them and then you know 50 years
later
like why didn't i tell her you know why
didn't i go after it
so that's the kind of that's the kind of
life regret that is very hard to
uh be happy about when you're telling
yourself
in a private moment that story of your
life
habit number six take many shots with
sergey brin
i'm very lucky to have been in silicon
valley and silicon valley is very lucky
to have
been able to benefit from you know the
semiconductor
boom and then software and now internet
and mobile i mean
i think it's there's a huge amount of
luck there
but the luck also comes from taking
many shots uh you know so many
failures you know if i told you all the
dumb things that i did
um you know we'd have to have much
longer session
and and the successes you know they
often are
chance i mean i mentioned the google
brain work that they were just off in
the corners like okay fine just
you know do your thing uh our um
you know verily which is uh our
subsidiary that does a wide range of
healthcare innovation now
uh really started with this glucose
sensing contact lens project
um and that was another one where i said
uh this fellow bobbuck and brian otis
who were working on it
uh you know and they wanted to put a
computer in a contact lens and i was
like you know what that sounds crazy but
you know you go do your crazy thing you
know you can only have a couple people
work on it i'm not gonna give you a lot
of resources
uh but uh you know sure if you put a
computer in contact lens good for you
uh and yet here they are
uh you know a few years later and
they're you know running uh you know
they're doing serious studies now they
have a big partnership with
artists and alcon uh and they are
um hopefully going to bring those to
market
alongside with a bunch of other projects
that that has spawned
and i didn't know anything about that
and i never would have predicted or
guessed
that i think we're just lucky to have
the environment that tolerates
you know making lots of risky bets and
tolerating the failures that inevitably
result
and habit number seven the last one
before very special bonus clip
is believe in people with charles koch
everyone has a gift
everyone can contribute if
they're empowered and so that's the
secret have a society
have institutions have people that
empower
others that enable them to
find their gift turn it into valued
skills
and then apply it in a way that enables
them to succeed by contributing to
others
and see how simple this is yeah and
i mean the problem is you need a society
that is relatively based on
the principles of equal rights and
mutual benefit where people succeed by
assisting each other
and everyone has the opportunity to
realize their potential
now that's utopian there's no society
that's been
perfect at that but even ones through
history
that have had a small degree of that
then
what these people can do that no one
suspected could do anything have done
extraordinary things and change
societies
and so that's what we try to do is go
find those people to solve a problem to
eliminate
injustice and then back them and combine
our capabilities with theirs
to enable them to do even more to help
even more people
what i call this is applying the
principles of human progress
this involves three different things it
because
it requires believing in yourself
believing in other people
empowering them from the bottom up
having them realize
that no one's good at everything we're
all just good at a few things
so we need to partner with people who
have complementary capabilities
so this gets to frederick douglass's
philosophy that made him such a great
uh social entrepreneur to unite with
anybody to do right
and no one to do wrong so those are some
of our guidelines
but as i say then the starting point in
all this
is to recognize that everybody can
participate in this
everybody can contribute and succeed if
you're a closed system
you close yourself off from the rest of
the world you try to do everything
yourself
and you're going to fall behind you
probably
die right quickly and that's true for an
organization
and that's true for society so what does
that tell us
it tells us things about immigration
tells us things about free speech and
open inquiry
it tells us about trade it relates to
ricardo's law of comparative advantage
division of labor
comparative advantage when that started
to be allowed
practice rather than everybody having to
do everything themselves
that's when prosperity started to take
off and poverty started to decline in
the 18th century
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you watch a video and you just get
motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action but
when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you you need to hustle while you wait if
you can
embody this advice and apply it to your
business on a day-to-day basis
this will be the biggest momentum shift
in your company this will move you so
close
to your goals at an incredible pace that
is unbelievable
just most people don't do it hustle
while
you wait listen with every goal that you
have
it relies on other people you need other
people to be a part of your process
right if you're
selling to customers you need the
customer to say yes they have to make
their decision
there's a bunch of back and forth if
you're waiting on a product to come
you're waiting on your supplier to come
forward
there's always things that are outside
your control that you're waiting other
people for
and yes when it comes to you you want to
get it done as soon as possible
if a customer's asking for a quote you
want to get it off your plate asap you
should not be
the bottleneck in momentum happening in
your business that's a whole other
problem
as soon as something comes to you it's
getting taken care of and you're
building momentum
but you're still even at the most peak
efficiency
waiting for other people to take action
that's gonna happen so what do you do in
those moments
you hustle you build new momentum you
build new clients
you build new relationships you maintain
the existing ones and get everything
done as soon as possible
and then in the downtime while you're
waiting for a decision
you're not just twiddling your thumbs
you're not just sitting on the couch
you're not watching netflix
you're off hustling new business quick
example
i was doing a photo shoot with richard
this guy's a celebrity photographer he's
done lady gaga
done the whole bunch of rappers he came
over and we did a photo shoot together
and in between his shots he's got to set
up lights he's got to
get his fog machine going he's got to
get the right angle he's got to set up
the green screen
and so when he needs me i'm there i'm
ready i'm posing i'm in action i'm ready
to go
but there's a lot of setup in between
shots and so what am i doing
i'm pulling up my phone and i'm
responding to you guys i'm making videos
i'm doing responses i'm getting on
twitter on instagram
i'm doing on snapchat i'm sending out
video responses to you guys
i'm working i'm hustling on my downtime
while i'm waiting for rich for this
project
i am hustling connecting with you guys
and that's the approach that you need to
take people say well how do i find the
time to respond to people on social
media
i probably have a way bigger counts than
you guys do and i find the time because
i make the time in between the other
things that i'm doing
this is so critical people are losing so
much time
the answer is not to wake up two hours
early or think that's gonna solve your
problem the answer is you're losing
time every single day you are leaking
valuable time
from your daily schedule and so i highly
highly highly encourage you to take this
message home
while you are working while people are
waiting on you for stuff you are
doing your best to deliver as soon as
possible so that you are not the
bottleneck in your business
but then while you are waiting on other
people you get
your hustle on you continue to build
momentum it is such a hack
to get you closer to achieving the goals
that you have for yourself
stop sleeping while you're waiting for
other people to get back to you
hustle while you wait
[Music]
if you want to know the routines that
billionaires do every day check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you have to do something for
10 minutes minimum if you don't have 10
minutes you don't have a life
usually before the sun comes up i offer
myself
to something greater than myself